what's interesting about it is people
are like well he's being attacked cuz
his name is Biden it's like no no no one
could do
that if my aunt found my uncle's laptop
and he had even one of the videos that
Hunter Biden had his whole life would be
ruined can you imagine that if anyone
found think to yourself you have a
laptop maybe in uh I don't know your
spare room your wife finds it your
husband your significant other other
your kids they find a laptop on the
laptop is photos and videos of you
smoking crack with
hookers in the
Ukraine
anyone anyone's life would have been
ruined this guy's doing well he's
painting he lived in Malibu up until
recently maybe still does this guy's
doing doing great there's no way my
uncle could have a laptop with photos
and videos of him doing the things
Hunter Biden did and end up in Malibu no
way no way no one no one if you recorded
every bad thing you've ever done [__]
hookers guns to their head lines of coke
cook and
crack if you recorded every single thing
you've ever done your life would be
ruined
over your wife would divorce you she
would take everything the judge would be
like buddy what the [__] you'd go into
rehab you could potentially be charged
with something I don't
know
documents texts and videos obtained by
Daily Mail show Hunter Biden spent a
staggering 30,000 on escorts in a
five-month period by the way 30,000 in 5
months you can do that that's not that
stagger I mean it's what I mean come on
he's not these aren't bottom of the
barrel [__] here he's got he's got
good [__] MH but can you imagine that
if you spent
$30,000 on escorts in five
months and recorded the entire thing and
then your wife found it you would be DOA
dead he's doing pretty good he's still
at the White House they still let him in
the white house he still gets to stand
on the balcony he's probably still
leaving cocaine in the white
house he had an art sh didn't Hunter
Biden have like a show of his work yeah
it was here in SoHo yeah he had a show
of his work in
SoHo this is not a guy who's like a
hopeless guy people well well it's he's
being persecuted because of his name no
no no no no it's his name which is the
reason that the guy can live in Malibu
and have art shows in SoHo no r regular
human being can spend 8 72,000 on
prostitutes porn and sex club
memberships take 1.6 million from
ATMs by the way it's a job as father got
him in the burisma [__] around in the
Ukraine that's how he has all this
money he's a lawyer lawyers don't have
any money anymore by the way anyone
listening to this thinking about
becoming a lawyer when you graduate law
school now you're you're in pover for
like 15 years you can't make any M
there's like 20 lawyers that have any
money it's not a lucrative thing anymore
doctors same thing you talk to the big
real estate agents you go who did you
represent 20 30 years ago they go it was
doctors lawyer they go now I don't have
one doctor one lawyer they can't afford
[__] it's all Tech Finance creative
people on a very high level and athletes
lawyers and doctors are out this guy's a
lawyer how the [__] he taking
1.6 out of an ATM it's because he had a
[__] job where there was a slush fund
which he used for hookers and blow and
by the way I'm not even moralizing about
any of that I've had my own problems I'm
not moral I'm not saying that this guy
should be
condemned I'm saying he's getting less
than what a normal person would get I
sat in uh AA for years years I still do
occasionally uh it's not Anonymous when
it's my program I keep other people's
anonymity I don't give a [__] whether
you know what I'm in or not I don't go
enough I should go more but I've heard
stories of how people's lives Get
Wrecked when they do what he's done I've
lived them right I lost a house my
credit got shredded I lived with comics
on couches and rooms in New York City
City for years working [__] jobs trying
to learn how to be funny there was no
art gallery show in SoHo there were no
high-end rehabs I didn't live in
Malibu I wasn't invited to the White
House that was not part of my sobering
up
journey I had tax problems too I had to
pay the [__] money I had to get a
shitty little lawyer that didn't really
care who tried their best and we paid
the [__] money back
I didn't really owe that much money he
owed a lot more than me but this idea
that like Hunter Biden's had it
particularly rough is
insane that's
insane it's crazy he's not had it
particularly rough I know tons of
addicts whose entire lives and they
didn't do a fraction of what he
did I know people who lost their entire
lives because they drank too much one
night and got in a car and and got
pulled over didn't hurt anyone didn't
kill
anyone didn't have uh you know 200
videos of Ukrainian human trafficking
victims [__] them with a gun to their
head they just made a left when they
shouldn't have they got pulled over they
lost their car they lost their job they
had to pay restitution they they didn't
have the money for it it took them years
to get their lives back
years so this idea that the Democrats
are going to like well it's
actually Hunter is paying a price that
other people don't pay he's paying far
less of a price than any drug addict
ever that's been caught with anything
and no matter what you believe
politically I don't care if you love Joe
Biden and hate Donald Trump you have to
agree if you're a rational person that
Hunter Biden is not paying the price
that other people have paid how many
drug addicts by the way are in Malibu
with an art show in
SoHo and I mean this is wild so Hunter's
four years of wild
spending he went nuts spending money
ATM's
1.6 2016 he withdrew
200,000 this is by the way a lesson in
Progressive uh drug use as well how it
gets worse 2016 200 Grand 2016's
probably not that bad he's smoking crack
occasionally couple of lines of the
powdered cocaa it's okay things aren't
great but it could be
worse
53,000 out of an ATM now he's not taking
this money out to tip
valet understand this money goes right
to the dealer I know I was a drug addict
for many years that's why when I'm
talking about him I'm not condemning the
act of using drugs I'm condemning this
idea that he's had it particularly rough
he hasn't 500,000 in 2017
2018 things get a little
unmanageable
$772,000 at of ATM or cash withdrawal
where he shows
up sniffling in a bank and goes I I got
to take some money out I need some money
now
and he goes in he's got a nice suit
because he spent a lot of money on
clothes that's the next thing coming
up clothing and accessories he spent a
total over this and so the last year at
77254 the exact same amount of money so
that's where he maxed out that's where
he was going to die he was doing about
$800,000 worth of crack a
year around that and
hookers hookers and cra crack that
800,000 of hookers and crack that was
his budge that was the budget in 2019
you're telling me you spent 800,000 on
hookers and crack two years in a row you
have a art show in SoHo no and nobody I
know no one you know by the I'm talking
about celebrities I'm talking about a
lot of people I'm not just talking about
broke people or middle class people I'm
talking about like people that I know
that have done really really well if
they had behaved like that it would be
over over there would be no second or
third act this guy's got the benefit of
his second or third Act and the only and
if he is being which he's not if this is
all
political and that's the only reason
that they're doing this and obviously
Nome may be involved in it trying to get
him out I don't know if he is or not it
doesn't make Nome look great either by
the way to to to show that this is you
know this he keeps talking about how
great Biden is this is his
son if he is being if any of this is
politically motivated it's because his
dad won't just not be the
president his dad won't just walk away
and let someone else
run so but I don't think it is like
here's the deal he's a known guy so he's
he's
being prosecuted because they know what
he did whether it's political or not
they they know what he did the crimes
are public they're out in the open he
didn't pay the taxes so this idea that
like you
know my favorite one is Health Beauty
and
Pharmacy in 2016 he spent 54,000 2017 he
spent
110,000 2018 46,000
2019 uh less 26,000 on health uniformacy
2019 he's like listen no condoms anymore
the condom budget's done we don't need
condoms honey you don't need tweezers
and Q-tips it doesn't matter no
condoms that's the only one that goes
down is Health Beauty and Pharmacy you
don't need Claritin get in the car get
in the
car you know 2016 he's really nice about
it he's like yeah go get go get whatever
you want get whatever you want what do
you what what do you need you want oh
I've all you girls love your nails go in
there and get nail nail polish remover
whatever you need I'll be in the car you
go in there and get whatever you want
2019 he knows these [__] for a while
he's like will you get in the [__]
car okay you know I'm clean we don't
need a condom you know I'm
clean my father's [__] gonna be the
president um so that sucks but we wish
we wish what do we wish him we wish him
well we wish him well